[Musica]
che possibilità ha un ragazzo comune
come ma senza particolari esperienze di
viaggio senza nessuna competenza di
meccanica di partire dall'italia da
palermo e raggiungere pechino la cina
quindi l'altro lato del mondo via terra
in auto pensate che quando partorì
l'idea del viaggio neanche ce l'aveva
un'auto non avevo neanche i soldi per
comprarne una tutta quella ho tutto
quello che avevo era un sogno
mosso dalla mia passione volevo
realizzare la mia idea prendere la più
umile spartana e comune auto d'italia un
vecchio pandino guidarlo via terra fino
in cina
questo è il pandino quando lo abbiamo
trovato era abbandonato sui monti del
messinese era pieno di topi era messo
talmente male che ce lo hanno regalato
per quanto era messo male appunto ai
rava mentre eravamo in tre quando nacque
l'idea del viaggio e quando partimmo
parti mentre a metà del viaggio di
andata gli altri due miei amici
tornarono a casa per ragioni diverse io
prosegue da solo
arrivai a pechino da solo e torna
indietro da solo quando di questo
viaggio
qui si concretizzò qui si concretizzò
quella che era soltanto l'idea del
viaggio a pechino col pandino fino a
questo momento era stato solo un idea
quando di quest'idea ne parlavo con gli
amici conoscenti ma anche con gli
sconosciuti nel luogo che frequenta ogni
sera a palermo e tantissimi rimanevano
affascinati altri incuriositi altri
ancora schiettamente si mettevano a
ridere tu con un vecchio bandino puoi
arrivare in cina via terra guidando ma
ha idea di dove la cina di cosa stai
parlando
smettila di dire fesserie erano i
commenti più comuni
sapete sapete cosa risponde voi o
costoro dammi il tuo numero di telefono
come mai ti arriverà una chiamata da
pechino
io arriverò a pechino via terra e ti
chiamerò tant'è che ho il cellulare
pieno di numeri memorizzati sotto la
dicitura scettico è scettica 2 cetica
tre sono tutti i numeri di quelli che
non credevano che io sarei arrivato a
per niente
alla fine non li ho chiamati diciamo che
è l'impresa è diventata di dominio
pubblico raccontato quasi
quotidianamente quando la connessione lo
permetteva il viaggio su instagram con
le storie di quello che succedeva
quotidianamente su instagram quello che
voglio sottolineare è chiaro
determinatissimo fin da subito fin da
quando mi è venuta l'idea del viaggio di
riuscire in questo viaggio costi quel
che costi
se ad esempio il giorno dopo la partenza
mi rubano la macchina io mica tornava a
casa avrei fatto l'autostop avrei preso
l'autobus avrei comprato un motorino
avrei fatto di tutto per arrivare via
terra in cina a realizzare questa mia
idea io sono convinto che è la nostra
generazione sta vivendo
l'apice della nostra specie in quanto ha
potenzialità siamo sulla cresta
dell'onda
ad oggi se hai accesso ad internet e
conosce un minimo di inglese ai a tua
disposizione una tale quantità di
informazioni ed esperienze
tali da metterti nelle condizioni di
apprendere in autonomia
tutte le nozioni di cui hai bisogno per
realizzare le tue idee a patto però che
sei mosso dalla passione è quella
l'unica forza motrice che può farti
realizzare i tuoi sogni
non basta posti un obiettivo è fare di
tutto per raggiungerlo quell obiettivo
deve essere la tua passione lo devi
sentire vivo dentro di te ogni giorno
dei bisogna loro la notte ed il giorno
ea questa forza motrice che è la
passione
sono convinto che va unito il
pragmatismo pragmatismo di capire quali
idee quali sogni sono realmente alla
nostra portata in questo momento della
nostra vita
sembra che parlando di pragmatismo io
stimo introducendo dei limiti che
stonano con concetti come passione
realizzazione dei sogni
io invece sono convinto che il
pragmatismo e una qualità giunta
indispensabile per capire realmente
quali idee e possiamo realizzare in
questo momento esempio se avete 40 anni
e avete la passione per la corsa ma non
avete mai praticato sport a livello
agonistico e vi rendete conto che avete
il sogno di vincere i 100 metri piani
alle olimpiadi
ora io non dico che è impossibile ma è
altamente improbabile che ci riusciate
in questo momento della vostra vita
rischiate di togliere tempo ed energie
ad altra idea ad altre passioni che sono
già dentro di voi hanno solo bisogno di
uscire fuori di essere realizzate quando
dovevo scegliere con chi e mezzo
effettuare questo enorme viaggio che
volevo fare via terra dall'italia alla
cina
due sono state le ragioni che mi hanno
portato a scegliere il pandino una
pragmatica doveva essere un'auto
economica non avevo soldi abbastanza
robusta è estremamente semplice dal
punto di vista costruttivo in modo te in
modo tale che ogni meccanico d'asia in
caso di necessità avrebbe saputo
sistemarlo anche se non ne avevamo mai
visto uno in vita sua
l'altra ragione era più legata alle mie
passioni non soltanto per il viaggio ma
per quello di provare a comunicare
qualcosa attraverso il viaggio infatti
uno dei messaggi che volevo arrivasse a
chiunque avesse anche soltanto ho
sentito parlare di questa vicenda era
chiesta è un ragazzo comune come e se la
più comune è umile auto d'italia e forse
del mondo riescono in qualcosa che può
sembrare straordinario allora davvero
per tutti c'è la possibilità di riuscire
in qualcosa di grande
a patto che
a patto che si seguono le proprie
passioni
quando sempre messi prima del viaggio
ne parlavo con amici sconosciuti sembra
nel luogo che frequento il mister a
palermo mi sono reso conto come tanti di
noi si pongono dei problemi dei limiti
in realtà inesistenti che sono quelli
poiché ti impediscono di realizzare le
tue idee
e se la macchina si rompe e se resti
senza benzina nel deserto e se ti perdi
e tantissimi altri se i problemi che in
un viaggio del genere ci saranno
ci saranno di certo è impensabile
considerare che in un viaggio così lungo
quattro mesi
attraverso queste nazioni tutto vada
liscio i problemi ci saranno ma allo
stesso tempo è impossibile prevedere
quali saranno o evitare che insorgano
l'unica cosa decente che possiamo fare è
avere un'attitudine mentale
tale che ci dia la consapevolezza da
subito che nel momento in cui i problemi
insorgono per che insorgeranno li
risolveremo in un modo nell'auto li
risolveremo ed andremo avanti come
d'altronde facciamo ogni giorno della
nostra vita
per quanto preparato potevo essere ad
ogni evenienza
mai avrei potuto immaginare di
ritrovarmi nella steppa del kazakistan
in mezzo al nulla e di dover
fronteggiare la paura di vedere un uomo
totalmente incappucciato con 30 gradi
che cavalcava verso di me ho mai avrei
potuto immaginare di dover dormire sui
monti altai che sono queste montagne che
separano la russia della mongolia dove
dormire dentro la macchina a freddo di
passare la notte è tormentato da un
grosso animale che si aggirava intorno
alla macchina e mi teneva sveglio forse
un orso di dove di svegliarmi dopo che
l'animale è andato via
sotto una copiosa nevicata che avrebbe
potuto impedirmi di raggiungere la
strada e in più il pandino non partiva
in quel momento ed ero solo sulle
montagne oppure mai avrei potuto
immaginare di guidare ore ore in
mongolia in mezzo alla steppa senza
incontrare nessuno credendo di essermi
perso e di ritrovarmi all'improvviso un
fiume in piena che sbarrava la strada e
di dover barattare del cioccolato con
della gente
del luogo per convincerli a tra in armi
dentro il fiume con il loro trattore per
andare avanti per superarle raggiungere
l'altra sponda
in quattro mesi di viaggio ne sono
successe di cose tantissime ma una è
quella che più di tutti mi ha colpito è
che in un certo qual modo ha confermato
una sensazione che io avevo fin da
subito fin da prima di partire è quasi
incredibile il modo in cui ogni singola
persona che io ho incontrato durante
tutto il tragitto quindi
indipendentemente dalla nazionalità
religione etnia estrazione sociale tutti
si sono sempre dimostrati benevolenti
nei miei confronti tutti mi hanno sempre
aiutato incondizionatamente
se non fosse stato per la gente che ho
incontrato durante il mio viaggio non
sarei arrivata in cina
e non sto parlando necessariamente di
aiuti reali per risolvere problemi
concreti
sto parlando anche del sostegno morale
che ho ricevuto da tutte queste persone
soprattutto quando poi sono rimasto da
solo viaggiare da solo è bellissimo a me
piace davvero tanto ti dà una sensazione
di libertà unica impagabile puoi fare
quello che vuoi sei totalmente libero in
quel momento puoi fermarti puoi andare
se in un silenzio tale che ti permette
di ascoltare il più profondo del suo
animo ma al contempo questa condizione
poi incupirsi po rattristarsi se da solo
non parli con nessuno deve risolvere da
solo tutti i problemi talvolta può
semplicemente buttarti giù di morale
nient'altro come quella volta in
mongolia quando dopo aver passato
un'altra notte dentro il pandino mi
sveglio riprende il viaggio iniziò ad
andare guidando nella steppa della
mongolia non molto lontano dalla strada
ad un certo punto vedo una famiglia
nomade qui non si capisce quello è un
camioncino
ci sono due persone che stanno montando
la loro urta questa tenda a casa mobile
che questa popolazione nomade della
mongolia usa smontandole rimontando a
spostandosi lungo i pascoli di questa
enorme nazione queste case bianche
queste tende bianche mi avevano sempre
affascinato fin dal primo momento in cui
l'avevo vista mi chiedevo come erano
fatte come fanno a resistere dentro
queste case a 40 gradi sotto zero
d'inverno una più 30 d'estate volevo
capire come erano fatte quale migliore
occasione di capire come sono fatte
quando c'è una famiglia che ne sta
montando montando una a quel giorno come
ho detto è incupito ero giù di morale
non avevo voglia di interagire con
nessuno viene anche pure un po la mia
timidezza la mia paura magari di dare
fastidio non so come reagiscono vado là
e non ho idea di come possano
quindi dopo aver rallentato con la
macchina decido di andare avanti perdere
l'occasione ripromettendomi però che la
prossima volta che mi ricapita mi fermo
e lì qualcosa scatta dentro di me la
prossima volta che mi ricapita facciamo
mente locale
cioè io sto io sto attraversando la
mongolia la nazione al mondo con la
minor densità di abitanti in assoluto
con un mio mezzo quindi ho la
possibilità di fermarmi dove quando
voglio e mi ritrovai esattamente nel
luogo in cui una delle pochissime
famiglie nomadi rimasta in quella
nazione sta montando la loro casa per i
prossimi mesi e io mi dico e ripeto la
prossima volta che mi ricapita la
prossima volta non ci sarà è quella la
mia unica volta mi sto prendendo in giro
quindi mi fermo faccio in versione torno
indietro mi fermo nel luogo in cui li
avevo visti scendo dalla macchina e
faccio un bel respiro e inizia a
camminare verso di loro con la testa
piena di dei dubbi e si arrivò la e mi
mandano a quel paese essendo fastidio
ssn fatti un po cammino quando sono
quasi arrivato da loro erano una coppia
mi rendo conto che la donna appena mi
vede inizia a sorridere
sorride allegramente è felice di vedermi
lascia perdere subito di lavorare e mi
invita a sedermi insieme a loro tira
fuori i biscotti dei derivati del latte
di non so quell'animale vi offre mi
offre del cibo cerchiamo di interagire
ma nessuno di noi parlava del cipro
caligo quindi finisce a risate
cerchiamo cerchiamo di fare un video in
cui salutiamo e io ero un rinato questo
incontro mi aveva rigenerato
completamente ero felice guardate e
questo loro accoglienza non è per nulla
scontata o banale immaginate io l'avrei
fatto noi l'avremmo fatto prima di
rispondermi voglio fare mente locale
immaginate io vivo in periferia una
piccola casa con un piccolo giardino
immaginate che un bel giorno di sole
sono sull'uscio a casa mia sto
sistemando la porta che malarici gola e
all'improvviso nel mio giardino
entra un ragazzo puzzolente sporco
trasandato visibilmente straniero magari
un africano e senza parlare una sola
parola d'italiano
inizia a camminare verso di me davvero
io lo avrei accolto senza fargli nessuna
domanda davvero lo avrei invitato ad
entrare in casa offrendogli biscotti e
cioccolato o come voi magari sta
pensando a ben diverso non è diverso
quella loro casa a quello e tutto quello
che loro avevano in quel momento loro
questo pensiero non l'hanno fatto
minimamente niente mi hanno accolto
allegramente spassionatamente e in
maniera genuina e come dicevo poco fa
questo incontro mi ha rigenerato ero
felice avevo voglia di riprendere strada
non ero più utili sta abbiamo voglia di
raggiungermi obiettivo di fare di andare
avanti mi avevano ridato forza ed ogni
volta questa sensazione mie ricapitata
ogni qualvolta la gente che incontro per
la strada mi accoglieva e non solo
quando mi invitavano a mangiare oa
restare nelle loro case sto parlando di
gesti comuni
un saluto di un pastore a bordo strada o
un sorriso magari di una bambina scalza
mirri generavano in ogni occasione e io
in quei momenti mentre ero in mongolia
mi sono ripromesso una cosa che una
volta tornato a casa
anch'io sempre mi sarei dimostrato
benevolente e gentile nei confronti di
tutti i viaggiatori che abbia incontrato
sulla mia strada che se fossero stati
una coppia di tedeschi in vacanza o un
ragazzo centroafricano emigrante e non
sto parlando
e non sto parlando necessariamente di
offrirgli la genio di aiutarlo cercano
un lavoro sto parlando di gesti
quotidiani che tutti noi possiamo fare
un sorriso un saluto una pacca sulla
spalla perché pregiudizio il pregiudizio
non porto annulla i confini ei limiti
che costruiamo intorno a noi alla nostra
persona non portano anche esse nulla
perché credetemi come ho visto sulla mia
pelle i confini quelli che vediamo sul
planisfero in realtà esistono gran parte
solo nella nostra testa e se ogni giorno
nella nostra quotidianità uscendo da
questa sala riuscissimo a fasci ispirare
un po più dalla dall'empatia e regalare
sorrisi e gentilezza gratuita gli
sconosciuti di riflesso vivremmo di
certo in un mondo più bello basta poco
[Applauso]
[Musica]